improvisational is all about how to
master things through change so I
thought I'd demonstrate that with a very
quick uh game or exercise and we'll talk
a little bit about that uh as well and
then we'll start to open it up into
happy hours a little bit more of
discussion so uh is there anyone willing
to uh come off of mute and help me with
this exercise
um it's pretty simple yeah Jamar is
already there he's good to go fantastic
so
um Jamar I'm gonna Spotlight both of us
just so we're able to see it and
um uh see both those and Jamar are you
familiar with the game new choice
or ding
never heard of either one okay so what's
gonna happen is I'll start and then we
may switch roles if you're feeling
comfortable with it but uh the way that
it works is uh I'm gonna start to tell a
story and at any time if you don't like
the uh kind of uh decision that I've
made or the direction that the story is
going you just kind of raise your hand
so I visually see it and just say new
choice and I'm gonna have to change
whatever it was of the last thing that I
just said I'm gonna have to change that
and go in a different direction with the
story okay and so you can kind of do it
whenever you want you can do it because
you want me to see a different choice or
you want to see if you want to just do
it randomly Etc does that make sense so
anytime you want me to do something
differently you just kind of say new
Choice uh for this story can someone
drop in the chat a suggestion of
um an animal uh Bianco is talking about
dogs so maybe let's get a suggestion of
an animal of some sort that's just going
to be what inspires my a parrot or a
raccoon chicken these are all fantastic
what was the first one cow
um that is one of my favorite uh my uh
daughter's favorite animals right now so
a cow fantastic so I'm gonna share this
story about a cow and again Jamar
anytime you want to raise your hand say
new Choice you're able to all right so
uh once upon a time there was a baby cow
named Lola and every single day Lolo
loved to go to the beach she loved to
swim and to Surf and to uh get a suntan
sometimes as well and one day uh Lola
was out at the beach and she got stuck
in the current so she got swept away out
into the water and luckily she found a
piece of wood that she could float on
and uh okay nutrition uh she found a
boat that she jumped into and on this
boat were some other passengers on there
there was a giraffe and a monkey and a
uh penguin all hanging out on this boat
and uh Lula was like man wow what a
creative a group this is and like yeah
we're all from the San Diego Zoo and uh
we are trying to escape uh because we
realize we want our own freedom and so
uh and because we really want to go and
eat some In-N-Out Burger
um because In-N-Out Burgers okay yeah
okay we really want to go eat some
In-N-Out burger and at first Lula was
like oh that's amazing then she's like
wait burger what kind of food is a
hamburger
and she's like is it ham because ham is
in the title and they're like oh no it's
technically a cow and she's like no we
are not going to In-N-Out Burger I don't
care how delicious those milkshakes are
and she tried to convince the other
animals why eating cows was bad she was
like first of all
um it uh is my brethren that you would
be eating second of all like methane
gases and stuff for the environment uh
third of all like don't you want like it
to try a lab-grown burger right there's
now lab-grown meat that you can try and
they're like you know okay okay maybe we
could all try uh some lab grown meat and
so they row their way to Shore and they
find themselves at San Diego so it's a
very hip town anyway and they found a
lab-grown burger spot and they go in and
enjoy some of the food so we'll end the
story right there uh excellent well a
round of applause to Jamar thank you for
for helping out um giving those choices
are you willing to try the opposite
Jamara are you willing to start a story
then I give you a new choices to come up
with something new one thousand percent
fantastic I love it so
um it can be a story about we got we
already got some suggestions uh we'll
say your suggestion for this is horse
whatever that means to you doesn't
necessarily have to be specifically
about a horse but that's just your
inspiration and I'll raise my hand and
say new Choice anytime uh you need to go
and start to go in a different direction
all right of course
uh so growing up in New York City I
always wanted a horse
but my mother told me that there is no
place to put a horse in New York City
new uh new choice
but we could get you a horse if you
lived out on the countryside with your
grandmother so I said Mom I'm willing to
go live for grandma because I really
want this horse and so I found myself in
the Bronx which is the furthest most
Borough north of New York City
and the horse that my grandmother got me
was a toy horse and it was one of those
four horses that kind of has a spring
action yeah it's a nutrition tomorrow
I'll get you a stallion
okay type uh the type of horse that I
had was a little pony and so this little
pony that I got was only three feet tall
and it wasn't very impressive because I
wanted a stallion I wanted a black
stallion but my grandmother said you
gotta learn to ride this Pony first and
when you learn to ride this Pony then
and only then I'll consider getting you
a stallion and so I took this little
pony named Tony out around the block and
people started to make fun of me I took
this Little Pony name Stella
and Stella your name
I took this Pony around named Ethel and
Ethel was the star of the Town everybody
wanted to pet her but I was like I want
to ride her I can't ride her if you keep
petting her and Ethel she knew that she
was a star and so she would run ahead
she was very disobedient and I said I'm
never going to learn how to ride Ethel
unless I can get people to stop petting
her and so I had to go out before I took
Ethel out and I had to pay people here's
a dollar don't pet Ethel new method for
not petting her
uh and so in order to get people to not
pet her I had to douse her with Vaseline
and I told them that Ethel had the
cooties and so as we as I said we'll
stop right there for the sake of time
but a huge round of applause to uh Jamar
that was fantastic so very nicely done
uh let me ask you how was how was the
exercise how did you feel oh you know
what it's so much fun it's like you're
stretching your synapses to like reach
for things and it feels like it feels
very exhilarating it's like a mental
it's like a mental workout